at the start of the movie a bunch of
teens have gathered up to participate in
a gaming tournament where the winner
takes 10 grand the only objective of the
game is to kill the other players and
get as many points as you can after the
game begins two players start
slaughtering all the other players one
by one hence racking up a lot of points
one of them is an aspiring newbie girl
while the other one is a pro who has won
several accolades in the world of gaming
as the crowd cheers on the veteran uses
his experience and takes the lead but
the Newbie girl still has an ace up her
sleeve she whips out a bottle of energy
drink called the impulse nine and drinks
it in one go which not only gives her
energy but also slows down the time by
100 times Dwayne The Rock Johnson tried
to get them to drink zoa instead but
they refused with this power she kills
all the players on site including the
veteran the girl eventually wins the
tournament and begins celebrating with
her boyfriend but little did she know
that her excitement is about to be cut
off in the most brutal way possible the
energy drinks bottle falls to the ground
and shatters causing the girl to snap
back to reality and when she does she
finds herself as an adult with three
children zoa wouldn't do that to you to
make matters worse she is living in a
dilapidated house with no electricity
and modern equipment outside the world
is turned into a Barren Wasteland and
even the oxygen has become poisonous to
breathe following this we rewind a few
days before the tournament took place
with the introduction of the girl Val
Hernandez she is a Brash up and coming
FPS gamer whose only dream in life is to
go professional and make a living out of
it the year is 2017 and Val lives with
her divorced father Carlos one day he
sets up Val for a job interview at a
diner and she reluctantly leaves the
house in formal attire outside her
boyfriend Evan comes to pick her up in
his car after they leave Val quickly
changes her dress in the back it turns
out that she's ditching her interview
and is going to a tournament of a game
called Field of Fire just like most of
the FPS Battle Royale games out there
Field of Fire is a multiplayer game
where the main objective is to be the
last person Stan ending thou figures
that if she wins first place she could
make a ton of money and build herself a
gaming computer however Evan pops her
bubble by revealing that a seasoned
professional gamer named Roy is going to
make a surprise appearance in the
tournament soon the two arrive at the
arena for the competition and see Roy
taking pictures with his fans before the
first match commences Heaven reminds his
girlfriend that she should not get
carried away and just focus on
qualifying for the finals however Val
has her sights set on beating the
Arrogant Roy after a while all the
players get Seated on their computers
and the game starts Val takes an early
lead but Roy catches up to her without
breaking a sweat he even interacts with
the crowd in the middle of the game such
is his confidence taking advantage of
this Val rack some points and is on the
verge of winning but instead of
finishing the game she decides to go for
the glory kill the plan quickly
backfires and Roy eliminates her in the
blink of an eye despite this Val
qualifies for the finals happening the
next day as the couple leaves the arena
Roy comes out in mocks Val before
proceeding to take more more selfies
with his fans and while Evan is away to
get the car a man named Kojima comes up
to Val and reveals that he knows the
secret to winning just leave Konami and
start your own Studio he says Val is
perplexed by the strange comment but
before she can say anything Kojima hands
her his business card and leaves when
Val reaches home she tries her best to
not make any noise but is caught
red-handed by her father left with no
choice she tells him the truth about
where she was during the day which
infuriates Carlos even more he then
orders her to go to the diner the next
day and beg for a job interview however
Val asserts that the tournament final
also takes place the next day which is
more important for her future and just
like any other parent Carlos tries to
make her understand that online gaming
has no future but the stubborn vow
ignores him and storms off to a room
shortly after she watches a podcast
about the game earlier in the day and
gets angry that Roy took the first
position just then she notices kojima's
business card and remembers him talking
about the secret to winning hence fueled
with vengeance and the desire to win she
decides to visit the given address soon
she reaches the golden saucer which
turns out to be a gaming Cafe inside a
couple of people are playing video games
on their computers and consoles soon
Kojima approaches her and instructs her
to sit down and play a game Val is still
confused as to why Kojima had given her
the business card but nonetheless she
gives the game a shot she cranks up the
game to the highest difficulty and has
trouble completing the level seeing this
Kojima hands her an energy drink called
impulse nine however he tells her that
it is no ordinary energy drink curious
Val takes a small sip of the drink and
all of a sudden everything that she
perceives starts to move in slow motion
as a result the game which was
impossible to play a while ago has now
become extremely easy for her suddenly
in the blink of an eye Val wakes up and
finds herself sitting across the table
from Kojima when she inquires as to what
happened he explains that impulse 9
stretches time for whoever drinks it and
that it has been an hour since Val had
sipped the drink he also reveals that
the amount of time stretched depends on
the quantity of intake of the energy
drink following this Kojima demands 500
for one bottle which shocks Val she
starts thinking that using the drink to
compete in tournaments might be cheating
but just then Kojima gets a call from
Roy and it's revealed that he also uses
impulse 9 to win games this is why he
has been labeled unbeatable by other
fellow Gamers and pundits after learning
of this Val eventually decides to buy
the bottle of impulse nine the next day
at the arena Val takes out the bottle of
impulse 9 and puts it by her keyboard
just before the game starts she takes a
small sip of the energy drink then using
the ultra slow motion she dominates the
leaderboard for a while seeing this Roy
also drinks some impulse 9 and starts
climbing the ranks ultimately reaching
the top this makes a Val desperate so
she chugs the entire bottle of the
energy drink regardless of the outcome
as a result time for Val moves at an
extremely slower pace and she uses that
to her full advantage eventually she
kills Roy's Avatar and wins the whole
tournament the crowd goes wild and
everyone cheers for her as well as Evan
as the couple kisses the energy bottle
falls to the ground and shatters all of
a sudden Val snaps back to reality and
finds herself sitting on a chair in a
dilapidated house she is holding a baby
and shortly after Evan comes into the
room wearing torn and filthy clothes he
puts the baby to sleep and tells Val to
get ready Val is super confused and
starts to hyperventilate after seeing
her fully grown adult body and a wedding
ring on her hand she runs downstairs for
some respite but to her horror two other
children call her mommy suddenly Val
throws up in shock and runs outside the
house she finds the neighborhood in
total disarray as people live in tents
with public bathrooms out in the open
here it's finally revealed that Val has
traveled to the year 2029 having skipped
over 10 years of her life in an instant
furthermore the town where they live is
enclosed by large walls which separates
it from the Wasteland that surrounds it
in the Wasteland dangerous creatures the
death lizards reside that are not
glorious for attacking humans because of
this the residents of the Town guard the
gate regularly and shifts moreover it
turns out that the people who had drunk
a large quantity of impulse 9 in the
past are only waking up now and are
called pulsers this resulted in people
snapping back to reality many years into
the future with no memories whatsoever
causing havoc and Chaos all over the
world however there is no accurate way
of knowing if one is a pulser unless
they snap back to the current time
furthermore since the apocalypse was
caused by the pulsars most people
despise them and rarely allow them to
stay inside the safety of the walls it
turns out the town's sheriff and Deputy
are Val and a man named Dan to avoid
ending up like the Pulsar Val hides the
fact that she too had consumed impulse 9
later at home Val tries to work out what
is happening she then recalls her father
Carlos and attempts to recall her last
meeting with him however when she turns
her head Val notices an urn with her
father's ashes on the mantle this
devastates her and she starts crying
profusely sure shortly after Deputy Dan
calls Val down for a latrine Duty she
initially declines but Dan reminds her
that she is a sanitation commissioner
and has to do the work as a result she's
forced to clean the dirty latrines for
several hours kids see what happens when
you don't go for job interviews many
days pass and Val starts getting
accustomed to the ways of the
apocalyptic neighborhood one day she
does every single task including guard
Duty Scavenging the latrine Duty she
picks up the kids from school where her
daughter Sophia gives her a drawing of
her saying that she is her hero however
Val is extremely exhausted and she
doesn't appreciate the little girl's
efforts kid I don't even know who you
are once she reaches the house she finds
Evan peddling a bicycle to power up a
game console as electricity is not
available to Val's surprise the game is
actually her favorite game Field of Fire
Val is overly excited by this and agrees
to play one round before putting the
kids to sleep after Evan heads out to a
social Gathering Val and the kids start
to game Into the Night hours pass by and
suddenly Heaven rushes inside it's clear
that he is terrified and informs Val
that she has missed her guard Duty shift
as a result Dan who is thumping on the
gate to be let in was killed by the deaf
lizards wasting no time the two rushed
to the scene where Dan's traumatized
wife is furious with Val filled with
guilt Val tries to go home but Evan says
that she still has to finish her guard
shift reluctantly she obliges after her
shift ends Val returns home with
agonizing pain she expresses her
feelings towards Evan who comforts and
reassures her before going to bed
thinking she has no place in the new
world Val decides to leave everything
behind and travel the wastelands as a
result she writes Evan a letter
admitting that she is actually a pulser
the next morning Val exits her
neighborhood with the intention of never
coming back while Evan reads the letter
and is in complete disbelief in the next
scene Val continues to walk the barren
land and soon comes across an abandoned
building it turns out that the
dilapidated building is actually
kojima's Cafe the golden saucer Val
hesitantly enters the gaming Cafe and
flicks around for a bit to her surprise
Kojima pops out of the counter however
she feels as if something is off she
realizes that Kojima hasn't aged a day
but he doesn't explain how as the two
chat Kojima finds out that Val had just
snapped back a week ago and he admits
that a lot of lives were ruined because
of the impulse nine drank however he has
a plan to rid her of all the sufferings
she has been facing as of late Kojima
brings out a large bottle of impulse 9
and tells her to drink it and if she
does she will never snap back into this
world this is because she will travel
hundreds of years in the future and by
that time she will already be dead why
not just feed herself to the death
lizards Kojima also suggests she play
her favorite game while going through
with it Val likes the idea and decides
to sit down to play Field of Fire but
when she leans forward to grab the
impulse 9 bottle she finds the drawing
that her daughter made for her and
becomes emotional Val then takes a trip
down memory lane and remembers all the
good moments she had with her children
and Evan as a result she abolishes her
plan to consume the energy drink and
instead heads back to the community to
reunite with her family at the gate an
Angry Evan is on guard Duty and he
refuses to let his wife in as she
betrayed everyone's trust Val apologizes
for everything and Promises to start
over and to make things right all of a
sudden the two of them hear gunshots
from afar and realize that it is the
death lizards approaching their
Community it's then revealed that the
death lizards are a group of normal
people who are cannibals and hunt on
others in the Wasteland so Evan lets Val
in and the alarms go off sending
everyone into a state of panic one woman
tells Val that everyone is going to the
Ravine as no one is prepared to fend off
the attackers hearing this an idea
strikes your mind since everyone in the
community feels betrayed by her she
plans to gain their trust hence she
tells her husband that she will be
staying back and holding off The
Intruders for as long as she can Evan is
sad to leave without her but when Val
tells him to go for their children he
obliges shortly after Val whips out the
large impulse 9 bottle from earlier and
gets ready for Battle the Death lizards
also make their way through the gate
ready to wreak havoc it's then revealed
that the lead of the death lizards is
none other than Roy himself the two
immediately recognize each other and Roy
reveals that he snapped back into
reality a few years back and now he has
become a barbaric leader who can kill
anyone he wants but despite his threats
Val is unfazed it turns out that she is
already down to the energy drink before
they arrived which becomes evident when
she tosses The Empty Bottle towards Roy
suddenly Val goes into slow motion and
opens fire on one of the gas canisters
sending the attackers flying a brutal
shootout ensues and Val manages to take
out almost all of them unfortunately she
gets shot in the stomach and shoulder
before falling to the ground all of a
sudden Roy comes out and he fires a shot
at Val but misses taking advantage of
the opportunity she shoots back and
successfully kills Roy following this
she fires off a flare with her last
breath signaling to Evan that the
community has been saved the movie ends
as Evan notices the bright red flare
while Val slowly dies subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notif vacations
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching